President Trump's
ex-National Security Adviser
is trying to cash in with a
tell-all book after refusing to
testify in Trump's
impeachment trial.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We all know the president
is a venal, corrupt,
self-serving maniac.
This much is plain to everyone.
Hell, it was the original title
of this show.
You don't have to peel back
the layers with Trump.
There's one layer.
It's a thick epidermis
of botox-infused pancake skin
wrapped around a dark howling
void where a soul should be.
Yesterday, for example, he
called in for yet another
televised therapy session
with Sean Hannity,
where he once again repeated
his insane lie
that the coronavirus pandemic,
which has now killed more
Americans than World War I,
which is growing in
about 20 states,
and which is spiking at
alarming levels in places
like Arizona and Texas, will
just magically disappear.
-It's fading away.
It's going to fade away.
Nobody knew that it was going
to be that contagious.
Nobody had any idea it was going
to be this kind of contagious
-Honestly at this point,
who's the audience for this?
I mean, obviously these
two guys will TiVo it
and watch it back later that
night while they talk
on the phone, but who else?
Mr. President,
you crushed that answer.
Well, you crushed that question.
Not only is this a flagrant
and reckless lie,
it's not even new.
When you buy the new
Steely Dan album,
do you really want the
track list to say,
"Reelin' In The Years
Remastered" 12 times?
And full disclosure, if they
were remastered as 12 different
versions of "Reelin' In The
Years," I guess I'd buy it.
Wait, are Fox News viewers just
Steely Dan fans but for Trump?
Trump has repeated a version of
this same lie dozens of times.
He's like a Big Mouth
Billy Bass of bull[bleep].
-It's going to disappear one
day, it's like a miracle.
It will disappear.
-Look, I know Trump's
diehard supporters
will never budge from
supporting him,
but are they really
sitting there
watching the TV saying,
"He's right.
No one new how
contagious it was.
My buddy told me you
could only catch it
by licking a toilet seat
under a full moon."
So we all know who Trump is.
Every tell-all book written
by a former Trump aide
about their time in
the administration
is the exact same.
Some of the details differ,
but they all say the same thing,
the most powerful man
in the world
is a mentally incontinent
man-toddler
with farina brain who
only cares about himself.
The one exception is
Sean Spicer's book,
which I think is called,
"The Beefing?"
No, no, wait, it was called
"Tales From A Podium Pud."
You know what I think it was,
"Stinky Tailor, Stupid Guy."
And yes, that was a tortured
"Tinker, Tailor, Soldier, Spy"
joke that almost worked.
You know what,
if you think that joke worked,
why don't you text "one"
to your grandmother.
And if you think it didn't work,
text "two" to your grandmother.
Either way, I think
your grandmother
will be happy to
hear from you.
Point is, if you're looking
for Sean Spicer's book,
you can find it at
Barnes & Noble
in the "Door Stop" section.
Anyway, every tell-all Trump
book confirms again and again
how uniquely cretinous
our president is.
And they are all equally
pointless.
We don't need tell-all books.
We have a tell-all president.
What he does behind
closed doors,
he also does behind open doors.
And windows, into microphones,
and his executive orders.
It would only be interesting
if behind closed doors
he was eloquent and curious
and not racist.
Then there would be
some all to tell.
And the same thing is true of
ex-National Security Adviser
John Bolton's new book, except
Bolton's book also proves
how loathsome and duplicitous
its author is.
You might remember Bolton as
the lunatic who's called for
bombing, like,
half a dozen countries,
who enthusiastically
cheered on the Iraq War
as a member of the
Bush administration,
and who helped dismantle
the Pandemic Response Unit
as a member of the
Trump administration.
Bolton has been a key figure in
some of the biggest disasters
of the last 20 years.
I'm pretty sure he was
Mr. Moustachelees
in the movie "Cats."
At least before they air brushed
out the [bleep].
Ya burnt.
Bolton hasn't expressed
so much as a scintilla of regret
for all the horrific stuff
he's been involved in.
In fact, he repeatedly
went on TV for years
and claimed that the Iraq War,
which killed
hundreds of thousands of people,
was actually a success,
and said the only thing he would
have done differently
in hindsight was leave the
Iraqis on their own sooner.
-I think the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein,
that military action was
a resounding success.
I think the mistakes that
were made subsequently,
setting up the coalition
provisional authority
and others that followed from
it, are lessons about what to do
after a regime
is overthrown.
What I would have done
differently is much earlier,
much sooner after the overthrow,
given it back to the Iraqis --
and I'll exaggerate
for effect here --
but given them a copy of
"The Federalist Papers"
and said "good luck."
-Spoken like a true psycho.
You're like a guy who goes to a
house party, gets drunk, vomits,
passes out in his vomit,
[bleep] his pants, wakes up,
then gives you an Emily Post
book of etiquette
and says, "You might
want to read this."
So Bolton has never faced
consequences for any of the
calamities he helped
bring about.
And now rather than
answer the call
when his country needed him,
he's cashing in
with a $2 million book deal.
And in that way, he is
exactly like Trump
and all the other ghouls
in the modern Republican Party.
He burned everything down,
stuffed his hands in the till,
grabbed as much cash
as he could,
and left everyone else to
clean up the mess.
Honestly, Trump should be proud.
[ As Trump ] A man after
my own, enlarged heart.
And I think if we listen closely
we're going to have a beep
coming up.
[ Gasps ]
Did you hear that?
It could be a few more minutes.
[ Normal voice ] And sure
enough, Bolton's tedious
and condescending book
does, in fact,
confirm every bad thing you
already thought about Trump,
including the impeachment case
Bolton could have helped
with months ago.
-Bolton says Trump did not
want to send funds to Ukraine
until they sent him dirt on
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden,
just as he was accused of doing
and acquitted by the Republicans
in the Senate.
Bolton says Trump told
the Chinese premier
to go ahead and build
concentration camps
for the country's
Muslim minority.
He also says Trump pleaded
explicitly face-to-face
with Xi, China's premier,
to, quote,
"Ensure he would win
the coming election."
-So not only did the
President of the United States
extort multiple countries
to help him cheat
in the 2020 election and
encourage a totalitarian regime,
to engage in ethnic cleansing
against a persecuted
religious minority, but
Bolton witnessed it all
but did nothing.
I pray that one day these two
get to share a cell together
in the Hague.
It would make for a great
buddy comedy.
These guys are a real
Turner and Douche.
It would be like a modern day
"Perfect Strangers."
And yes, in this situation
Trump would be
the Balki Bartokomous
character.
[ As Trump ] In my country,
we drink water with both hands.
Don't be ridiculous.
[ Normal voice ] So let's see,
we got "Perfect Strangers,"
in there today, "Steely Dan,"
"Turner and Hooch,"
and "Tinker, Tailor,
Soldier Spy."
So I think we've more than taken
care of our teen viewers
this evening.
Also, I can't wait
for all the fake China hawks in
the GOP like Ted Cruz
and Marco Rubio to pretend they
haven't read Trump's comments.
Cruz is gonna grow
a beard so thick
reporters won't be
able to find him.
And yes, Bolton's book is also
full of the typically
embarrassing details you'd
expect to hear about life
in the Trump White House.
For example, you might remember
that Trump coined --
coined -- the nickname
"Little Rocket Man"
for Kim Jong-un.
But then after their summit in
Singapore, Trump pretended the
name was a compliment and tried
to send Kim a gift.
"In the months following the
summit, Bolton described Trump's
inordinate interest in Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo
delivering an autographed copy
of Elton John's 'Rocket Man'
on CD to Kim during Pompeo's
follow-up visit to North Korea.
Trump had used the term
'Little Rocket Man' to criticize
the North Korean leader but
subsequently tried to convince
Kim that it was a term of
affection.
'Trump didn't seem to realize
Pompeo hadn't actually seen
Kim Jong-un during the trip,
asking if Pompeo had handed
the CD, wrote Bolton.
'Pompeo had not.
Getting this CD to Kim
remained a high priority
for several months.'"
Okay. First of all, I love that
it was a CD in the year 2018.
Knowing Trump, his plan was to
get Kim Jong-un to pay a penny
for that and 11 other CDs
and then have him on the hook
for the rest of his life.
"Classic, Columbia House."
Second, it's so weird to give
someone an autographed copy
of a CD that isn't yours.
For Christmas one year
I gave my mom "Wolf Hall"
but I didn't sign it.
So a con artist warmonger is
cashing in by detailing horrific
abuses of power by a con
artist president
subverting our democracy,
and all the while the Republican
Party is just standing by,
letting it happen.
We're all watching right now
as our institutions fail us
in a time of acute crisis.
Police are beating protesters
with impunity,
a deadly pandemic
is ravaging the nation,
and unemployment is higher
than it's been in a century.
And many people who
thought the government
would be there to protect them
are learning that it's not.
It's like being on an airplane
and assuming the oxygen mask
will be there in an emergency,
and then you hit some turbulence
and the only thing that comes
down is a voucher that says,
"We know you have many
choices when you fly.
Thank you for choosing us,
and please, rest in peace."
And in many ways, the various
crises we're experiencing
right now are connected
in at least one sense.
The structural inequality and
the institutional failures
laid bare by the coronavirus
pandemic helped set the stage,
in part, for the unprecedented
mass demonstrations
against systemic racism
and police brutality.
-I think we were primed for
this moment by the coronavirus.
By a lot of the American
mythology being laid bare.
One, the idea we can be
relentlessly upwardly mobile
and that white folks have
sort of their grasp
on the American dream.
When the economy shut down
and people realized they were
two paychecks away
from destitution
and the government may
not be there for them,
there was a sense of
vulnerability
and a physical vulnerability.
And then as we saw, the
coronavirus made people
lean into their neighbors.
Once you tap into that source of
vulnerability, interdependence,
humanity and and awareness
of inequality
that the coronavirus
has exposed,
you're primed for
something big.
-She's right.
The pandemic made the
failures of our institutions
very real
for tens of millions of people.
And in turn, it led to a deep
sense of community solidarity.
People had to look out
for each other
because they realized the
government wouldn't,
by checking on neighbors,
supporting local businesses,
and liking your friends'
Instagram pics
of their janky banana bread,
even though they have already
posted half a dozen
banana bread pics, and they are
not getting any better.
You're over-mixing
the batter, Steven.
[ Sighs ]
Your bananas aren't
ripe enough.
It [bleep] breaks my heart
to tell you that, Steve.
Your bananas aren't
ripe enough, bro,
and you're embarrassing
yourself on social media.
People are discovering that
their government just isn't
there for them, thanks in part
to years of concerted efforts
by the moneyed class
and the corporate elite
to hollow it out.
If every year you pump trillions
into corporate tax cuts
and the military and cut
everything else,
you're gonna end up with a
country where millions of
people don't have jobs
or healthcare,
billionaires are doing great,
and everyone else
is met with tear gas
and riot gear.
I mean, think of what else we
could be spending money on
right now instead of tanks for
local police departments.
And even if you really want to
spend the money on tanks,
the least you could do
is give them to nurses
and postal workers
instead of the police.
If instead of a tiny little
mail car, every postal worker
had a tank,
they would make damn sure
you got that Pottery Barn
catalog.
In fact, one small thing we
could keep spending money on
are the additional unemployment
benefits provided by
the coronavirus
stimulus package.
As you might recall,
the bill added $600
to unemployment benefits,
which Republicans
tried to get rid of at the time,
a move that enraged
Bernie Sanders.
-And now I find that some of
my Republican colleagues
are very distressed.
They are very upset
that somebody who is making
10, 12 bucks an hour
might end up with a paycheck
for four months
more than they received
last week.
Oh, my God, the universe
is collapsing.
Imagine that.
Somebody who's making
12 bucks an hour,
now like the rest of us, faces
an unprecedented economic crisis
with the 600 bucks on
top of their normal,
their regular unemployment check
might be making a few bucks
more for four months.
Oh, my word.
Will the universe survive?
-Say you what you will about
Bernie, but we really missed
An opportunity for some
grade A old man sarcasm
in the debates with trump.
Oh, the media is mean to you?
How will the universe survive?
You know what we used to do
when someone was mean
to us back in my day?
We didn't tweet.
We rode our bikes
down to the sandlot
and challenged them
to a game of baseball.
On Sunday, Trump
economic adviser
Larry Kudlow said the Trump
administration would cut off
the additional $600 because
it somehow disincentivizes
people from going back to work.
-The federal government
program for unemployed Americans
gives them an extra $600
a week in benefits.
But it's slated to
run out in six weeks.
Now, obviously the health
effects and economic effects
are going to last
longer than that.
Should American families that
are receiving these extra
$600 checks right now expect
that money to stop in August?
-Well, unemployment benefits
will not stop in August.
What may well stop -- and this
reform is necessary -- almost
all businesses, frankly,
on both sides of the aisle,
or mostly both sides
of the aisle,
understand that the $600
plus up, that's above
the state unemployment benefits
that they will continue
to receive is, in effect,
a disincentive.
I mean, we're paying
people not to work.
It's better than their
salaries would get.
-I don't know. I think that says
less about unemployment benefits
and more about how
little we pay workers,
you senile business egg.
Also, I love that he thinks all
these people are on a salary.
Oh, so you're a driver
for Papa John's?
What is that, 100k a
year in stock options?
I bet you get stock options,
I presume.
So you think we're paying
people not to go to work?
We're paying them because our
sociopathic government failed
to protect them from
a deadly disease,
and our barbaric capitalist
system
has rendered
them expendable.
Not everyone can spend
their day golfing
and watching TV like
the guy you work for.
if we're paying anyone
not to work, it's him.
The only way Trump could watch
more TV is if golf courses
started putting tiny screens
in the bottom of the cup.
The people at the top are
stuffing their hands
in the till, trying to cash out
before everything burns down.
And meanwhile, they won't even
let you keep an extra $600 bucks
a week during a pandemic
they failed to stop.
I've got to be honest, sometimes
it really does feel like --
-The universe is collapsing.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As New York struggles
to re-open,
remember that we're
still a city in crisis,
and City Harvest has been
stepping up to meet
the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.